more than four months after the deadly
assault on the u.s capitol the house is
expected to vote today
on forming a bipartisan commission to
investigate how hundreds of trump
supporters
stormed and vandalized the home of
congress republican leaders want their
members to vote against
the compromise plan that one of their
own worked out with democrats
nicole killian is following the back and
forth on capitol hill nicole
is that enough to block this bill for
moving forward well this bill to
set up a january 6 commission is
expected to
pass the house today with or without
republican support and
speaker pelosi did try to bring
republicans along
last week there was a bipartisan
agreement to
establish a 10-member panel that would
be evenly split between
democratic and republican appointees who
would have subpoena power and that even
split
was a concession by democrats republican
congressman
john katko helped reach the deal but now
his party is splitting off yesterday
house
minority leader kevin mccarthy came out
against the agreement
because it ignores what he calls
political violence an allusion to some
of the events during last summer's
demonstrations later that day the former
president said house and senate
republicans should not
approve the commission calling it the
democrat trap but keep in mind the goal
of the commission is to get to the
bottom
of what went wrong on january 6 and how
to prevent
a future attack recently ousted gop
conference chair liz cheney thinks
mccarthy should testify because he spoke
with then
president trump during the riot and some
lawmakers believe mr trump
should also be called as a witness but
even if this bill
passes the house senate democrats would
need
at least 10 republicans minority leader
mitch mcconnell
has said that he wants to see the fine
print but cbs news has learned that he
told senate republicans behind closed
doors
that he cannot support the commission in
its current form
back to you nicole killian thank you
very much